these explosions are what Kashmiris
feared the most they have to rush to
safety when mortars and artillery shells
hit their area both sides exchanged fire
regularly across the line of control
that divides India and Pakistan these
images were filmed on the Pakistani side
just days before India revoked partial
autonomy in the part of Kashmir it
overseas civilians on both sides have
suffered when tension increases between
the two militaries one child was killed
and others were injured in Neelum Valley
in the latest shelling from the Indian
side Pakistani soldiers say cluster
munitions were used and hundreds of
unexploded bombs are scattered over an
area approximately 10 kilometers wide
many homes were hit with shrapnel from
artillery rounds we didn't see anything
we just heard the sound our house was
filled with smoke my grandmother called
for a vehicle and then they took us to
hospital the Pakistani military did not
allow us to film in the open because it
says there is danger from posts like
this one on the Indian side behind me is
a district of state wall which shows the
proximity between Pakistani and Indian
administered Kashmir and how people are
caught up in the violence in another
village near jacoti crossing there is an
uneasy calm being close to the frontline
people here are under an ever-present
threat they are trying to teach their
children to forget the fear from the
last time they were hit by mortar shells
here we live in danger our children are
always scared we don't have a shelter to
hide in and at night we can't sleep
every time there is shelling our
children's education is affected because
they can't go to school for weeks they
build these on self-help phases in case
shells begin to drop from the Indian
side they want Indian forces to stop
targeting civilians and remind the
Pakistani government to live up to its
promises to provide better security
because their time we won't go on a bus
or an whare they can begin shelling at
any time as they have done before these
bankers were built with our
money and the government gave us nothing
despite promises for compensation and
funds to build shelters the disputed
Kashmir region is one of the world's
most dangerous flash points between
nuclear-armed rivals the ridge on the
right is in India and the one on the
left is in Pakistan its own to around 2
million people and multiple UN
resolutions already exist on the issue
but the latest crisis has again
highlighted 72 years of failure in
finding a solution for Kashmiri
Tamil enjoy without Hazira at the line
of control pakistan-administered Kashmir